this is Startalk if we're gonna go to
Mars do you do you see engineering
challenges to that or is it only no no
no this is a very serious question
engineers love a challenge so don't tell
me don't don't play that with me a B
bring it on don't bring it on don't even
so my question is is it just a matter of
money or even if I gave you as much
money as you want you might not be able
to solve some of the engineering problem
oh we can solve the plan that that's no
we can solve yeah because we Land Rover
from a freakin rocket crane right we can
solve the problems but as far as this
colony idea everybody okay yeah it's I
mean there's no liquid water as such
mm-hmm oh well Mars was once very wet
and we found evidence of ice all good
but it's not like there's a river there
right okay then the other is its
underground and no one has found it yet
okay and let me just go on to say it's
on this summer day at the equator it's
20 below okay yeah you can get what is
it everybody wearing this year canada
arctic crew that was a goose down canada
goose down brand jacket all very good
that's dead that's when things are
really good that's all you got if it's
midsummer
midsummer guitar the main thing i think
you would pick up on right away there's
no air you would suffocate in a second
well there's air but there's no oxygen
in the air so you just have to make all
that stuck but somebody's thinking about
the future here to stop you there
bill quiet oxygen in the air that's
carbon dioxide is separated from your
carbon carbon carbon dioxide co2 is one
of the most tightly bound molecules ever
made I mean you can do it but you got to
put in the energy you gotta put in the
end man you're gonna be living everybody
you're gonna be living in a submarine
but just to be clear so you have to get
that energy from somewhere right right
so justjust there's no such thing as a
free lunch and your one and a half times
the distance that we are from this
so your solar energy if you just want to
run if you wanted to run solar panels
was 15 squared so it's a two and a
quarter to two and a quarter times more
less to a quarter times more solar panel
this conversation well it is the next
logical place to look for like Chuck
getting high pitch on it you want to go
there is because you're gonna explore
and when you explore two things happen
those two things doc Chuck why you will
make you will make discoveries okay
you'll never find something you never
found before all right but the other
thing is you will have an adventure you
will have an adventure it will engage
you like nothing else
whether it's your backyard the video
game or the surface of Mars
now you might die but it'll be an
adventure what we want to do as an
engineer and this is what astronauts say
part of their pride as being astronauts
is coming back that's like landing the
airplane as part of a pilot's pride I
mean ejecting and letting the 350
million dollar fighter plane explode
it's kind of cool on video yeah but it's
not really your goal as a pilot or an
astronaut so if we were to go there with
a human we would be able to make
discoveries at an extraordinary rate
it's estimated 10,000 times faster than
our best robot spacecraft right now but
if the day comes when we have a ten
thousand times better robot you'd still
probably want to excel want to send a
okay so then and so here's the thing if
we found evidence of life fossilized
bacterial mats or cooler yet something
so alive some Mars krob then the
question would be and I want to know do
those Mars probes have DNA like you and
I do or are they a whole nother another
of nother Ness Mars krob that's the
Martian microbes Martian microbe Mars
krob and then if they have DNA and
there's so much like us does that mean
Mars was hit by an impact or who went
off into space and you and I are
descended of more
Russians we'd all be marketed this is
Startalk